good morning we're ready to go ahead
here with the continuance of our
community conference on hb 1661.
uh so uh we did have uh i'd like to
address uh
the uh sb 400 portion of the bill and we
did receive a amendment from
um
senator bradley here and if senator
bradley could please explain that so we
everybody has a copy in front of us here
i think there's copies available for the
public as well
good morning
uh mr chair this is ours okay thank you
so um
based on the conversation that we had
the other day
i
um took it upon myself to draft the
following amendment 2025.
it dealt with the housing piece
the senate for
senate bill 400 piece
um so section 83
i deleted the
last sentence and put a period after the
word development
i think that representative turcotte may
want to discuss that further
and then
on 92
and
93 added
section
5 and
on the next page j 93
and that's to allow
um
separately
separately adopted ordinance
and i
the thought was to try to give greater
um
participation by the voters or voter
approval
for the tiffia financing
so that does provide greater voting
approval by the legislative body and it
allows for the the posting of that
hearing and all in accordance with
statute and i worked with a municipal
association
um on this language and i think natchez
here he just
yeah there he is so um they thought it
worked for
cities and
towns okay so let's have uh
representative
you know
your name was referenced here by the
senator
can you respond to that particular
section um yeah
although i think
the attempt was made to actually uh
get language in that brought on the
point i brought up the other day on i'm
talking 92 and 93 right now go back to
83 in a minute
i do not believe that the language in
the amendment captures
what we were trying to accomplish and
i'll explain
my concern was that
any
municipality that has adopted the
municipal economic development and
revitalization district and does anybody
know
are there those
already existing in the state has there
been there are so i'm okay
so my my issue was that by adding the
language in uh
in five
it was a it was effectively bypassing
the town's ability
uh to have a say in whether they wanted
that particular
issue
in in
the uh develop the revitalization
district and that's because
before a municipal economic development
district is can be brought into a town
or municipality or city it has to be
voted on by the legislative body or
the
people
citizens at a meeting so the intent of
what i was trying to do was say
okay we're okay with that language
of
but we want the voters and or the
representatives of that town
to specifically
utilize
rsa 162k1 which is called the local
option which is an affirmative vote to
bring that piece
into their existing
municipal uh
revitalization district and again i i do
not believe the language that's provided
does that i just passed out what i
originally given uh to senator bradley a
couple days ago man maybe a day ago
and i i believe that captures the
essence of exactly what we're trying to
accomplish um it may not be perfectly
worded um and it's not in an amendment
form
but
the what's trying to be accomplished i
think is much better captured in that
language
um
back to paragraph 83
i i think the only other thing
the only other thing we'd like to see in
that and again it's it's it's because of
we don't want
things forced on municipalities and that
would be
um in the
amendment i just handed out here
where it says if a municipality allows
an increased density i just changed the
word there to permits and increased
density but the important part is right
after it mentions rsa
354 a15 8
i've strike a struck in the words shall
allow
and inserted may permit and that again
is to give the municipality
the decision rather than the state
handing down a mandate
so those those are the only two things
uh
like i say i i like the
the wording of ours better i think it
actually captures um
i've read through the amendment that
senator bradley passed out several times
and i just don't believe it captures
what
the issue i was trying to raise thank
you
thank you
uh any uh discussion on this now we so
we have two uh
potential perspectives here
both referencing
162k colon 1.
would it be appropriate to hear from
natch of the municipal
association sure as to what's workable
for them
thank you
thank you senator does he have a copy of
the amending language of both of them
does he have the bradley amendment as
well
i i've seen i've seen both amendments uh
mr chair okay um i don't have senators
uh thank you for the record nature grace
for the new hampshire municipal
association um
so i guess i will uh address sections 92
and 93
first
i believe that the amendment that
senator bradley handed out effectively
does the same thing as um representative
turcotte's uh the language is slightly
different but
uh it does say that if separately
adopted by the city or town
by the procedures described in rsa 162
k1
so
that separates out this new section 5
from
and section j
from the existing definition of public
use under 92 and then
um
the district establishment under 93
and so you'd have to have a separate
town meeting vote if you have a town
meeting or
in a city council or a city um a
city council vote in order to adopt
um those provisions so effectively it
does
the uh the same thing um
i just think the language might be a
little bit clearer in senator bradley's
amendment
as far as section 83 goes
um
i don't see any legal difference between
the term allows and permits
effectively the same thing
although it is um the case that if you
were to change shall allow
to may permit
um that would make that would shift um
workforce housing from being something
that is
necessarily linked to um
housing for older persons in terms of
any sort of
any sort of incentives
to something that is just permissive and
would not would not put a requirement on
municipalities
i hope that's helpful but i went through
that rather quickly so i'm happy to
answer any questions
thank you
thank you uh other questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
so is the committee
good with either one of these i'd like
to try to start getting some of this
accomplished
at least in terms of section 92 and 93
my language
which i think he said is a bit clearer
it has the same intent as representative
turcottes so i would hope that we're
okay with that in terms of
83 um
the whole
point of 83
is
if a community is going to have um
elderly housing
then with incentives then it would have
workforce housing with incentives i mean
one
potential option would be
to pass
83 the way it is in this amendment but
with a sunset clause
of say five years see how it works um
you know and the legislature would have
to reauthorize it so that would be
you know one thing that i could live
with i haven't had a chance to share
with my senate colleagues but hopefully
they could live with it too and i think
that would i think that would be
you know another
um guardrail so to speak
senator d'alessandro you had your
speaker on as well just a quick if if
indeed uh senator bradley's
concept can you can you lower that
please right if if senator bradley's
concept is accepted then we would take
the language that he's presented in his
in his amendment 2025 s and the shall
allow should be uh in it
rather than the may permit correct
i i think
yeah
that
in both 92 and 93 are acceptable to
representative turcotte because
basically according to the testimony
we've just heard they're exactly the
same
so
the what what we're talking about is two
words
shall allow versus may permit
with the possibility of a sunset
provision with the possibility of a
sunset provision representative yeah
thank you um and again i
on 92 and 93 it if the intent is
actually the exact same thing as as i'm
suggesting in my language and again my
language is
it is slightly different but to me it's
more it's more clear
as
i'm always
concerned about the intent
going forward
and i'm not quite sure
um
the bradley amendment it
gets that attempt intent
across as well i'm willing to look at it
some more
as to 83
whether the word allow stays in or
changes to permit that's not my issue my
issue is the shall um
i i believe uh just as easily we could
put may in there and we could have a
sunset position um
on a may um
i i
dislike telling towns you must do this
and that's what shall
the word shall means you know there's a
wide range of words we can use shall
could would may
um and shall's the most definitive of
them all and um
for me i i would need to see a may in
there
thank you mr chair
thank you
further discussion yes representative
carnelli thank you um
yeah i think
it might be down to one word but it's a
minor important word there and uh i i
think um
i agree with what uh representative
turcotte said and also um we've received
a lot of comments um
both from the public and from our caucus
about
um
section related to 400
and i think
the
may versus shall
would also be
a major point in taking this back to our
caucus
thank you
so it looks
as if there's just uh primarily we're in
in concurrence on 92 and 93 the intent
and hearing the department say that
that they're reading it the same way
so the issues primarily now with 83
and
that word may
and possibly scooting around that with a
sunset provision
clause
so we need to you know put this aside
now and we know that there's there's a
possible way of steering the ship
through this part of our task
are there before we drop 400 uh
representative do you have anything else
on 400
no nothing other than that other than
the
um
do they end up passing out the full
amendment
with all the
deletions i think senator bradley we did
that the other day am i correct we
passed out and then we were only down to
these
these three issues really these
paragraph
we had agreed to take out sections 86 89
90 and 94.
you would agree to
keep in all of the other
sections other than
83 92 and 93. yeah did i confuse
everybody
i do believe we are okay with the
exceptions of these three paragraphs i
would of course we have time we will
confirm that but i don't believe there
are any other issues on 400
okay and i had that that communication
also so i think we're we've got that
noted too now so we're closing in on 400
um is there need for any more discussion
on 400 at this time
for the conferees 420 is totally out of
the picture now that was resolved
yesterday and so we will not be uh
discussing 420 that is out of this bill
it's been handled through the conference
there
and i would just say
i haven't had a chance to consult with
senator d'allesandro but i think senator
hennessey's fine yes i'm fine are you
fine with that senator d okay thank you
thank you so we've communicated on that
that extraordinary needs grant is going
forward with accountability within it
and the 300 to 500 is out
alrighty so
next i guess we need to address uh
430.
and where we are on this uh
all the way from roman numeral 3 to
roman numeral 25 on the bill itself
um
i i had a discussion with some folks in
the health and human services earlier
this morning
and there are some portions of 430 which
are technical corrections that were in
the
original house version of 430
which will enable the department be in
conjunction with what is happening in
reality
um
so i i i think somewhere along the way
we need to have this discussion and i've
asked that those
areas be
marked as far as
which ones
are not in the floor amendment which
were in our house bill as came out of
the house
committee
okay so backing up a little bit where i
was when i was reviewing again
this legislation last night at midnight
uh i saw sections dealing with the
glencliff home
and and and and uh being able to
provide uh incentives for folks to come
in
finding these nurses now is very
difficult they're in competition with my
area with with hitchcock big time and
even with grafton county home and with
the cottage hospital
and so they're they're looking at
anything being able to award up to ten
thousand dollars to attract these nurses
to the facility
um there are there's also some cleanup
in regard to um
the uh
some of the uh funds which were paid
earlier this year
and then this is just one small area
um i had another question about the
kinship uh care homes which is in this
thing
and where there can be an exception and
extending from 30 days to 100 days 180
days
placing children into these facilities
which are not licensed and i was just
asking
is there oversight of these facilities
during the extended one-half year period
time
if these things are not critical to you
know and we're in the original version i
can't see any reason why we wouldn't be
moving those parts forward
any discussion
yeah
as discussed the other day
multiple times
this bill is
will not be part of a complete package
of 1661.
um
it's a bill that can be brought up
uh
in six months they can uh put it forward
then
it is a bill that the senate had the
opportunity uh to call a separate
committee a conference on they declined
that
they non-concurred
and then took
our 430 less the floor amendment and put
it on here this bill
will
will not be part
of
the 1662.
thank you
i'm sorry i just came from 1662. 1661
yeah we're in one today
okay um
is there a response
it looks to me like where we're coming
from now is that 430 should not be part
of this bill
so
um
i think
we may need to
reconvene
on this issue um
i somewhere in my pile of papers here
have the
docket i can look it up easily and
quickly
but i suspect that
representative umberger can illuminate
on this i believe that the house pass
version of 430
passed
out of the finance committee the house
finance committee 20 to nothing
went to the floor there was the
amendment added that i believe was house
bill 1044 which dealt with hospitals
the senate rejected that
added
the balance of 430 back to
um
this bill 1661 but
the point i'm trying to make is i think
the house passed virtually all the
sections of
house bill 430 i think it came out of
your committee representative berger 20
to nothing so i'm kind of mystified as
to why it's a problem today
that it would be a problem for me and i
suspect for my senate colleagues
a big problem
and i'll be happy to address that one as
i've explained now multiple times the
issue is not
so much the content of the bill or it
was how
it was
we went we did not have a
committee or conference on the bill by
itself and that the senate chose to
non-concur
the
the number of items in the bill alone is
a problem for many on our caucus we've
had the discussion
that the more that is added to 1661
um
representative cordelli mentioned it on
400 alone
when you have 400
and 430 on it 430 as of now is not going
on anyway but the more you add on to
that
we are going to have
issues with our caucus now
i i attempted to explain that the the
senate has a little bit different
dynamic with 24 of you than
we have with over 200
trying to corral 200 into
a a vote if you will so the votes that
you're seeing
coming out of
finance is one thing what you saw on the
floor
is
totally unrelated to what actually went
on to get us to that point
of including
430 along with the floor amendment so
again
as
as of the moment
430 is not going to be part of this bill
if you were to
say
we want 430 more than we want to attempt
to
go with
400 that might be an option but
400 as we've
as you've seen by the house floor boats
400 is not admired by the majority of
our caucus and some on the other side of
the aisle so you want to start adding
all these things in there
it's
the entire
the entire thing is going to go down
well that would be unfortunate because
i think we need to build a parking
garage but if we're at loggerheads i'd
suggest we reconvene tomorrow
i'd i'd like to just say
my two cents that
as the prime sponsor of 1661
this bill was designed originally
and a result of
approximately five to six years of hard
work with the directors of the cte
centers throughout the state with the
advisory councils with business
trying to align what we're producing out
of our schools k through 12
a commodity which business and industry
manufacturing
recognize has the skills to
be successful in other words the student
and we need to double the number of
students we coming out of our high
school situations
with this skill understanding to
properly prepare and maintain industry
and manufacturing in the state
and we're not doing
it and this bill provides the
opportunity for students to attain the
graduation carnegie units the graduation
requirements the 20 required
for a student attending a cte course now
to get those credits not necessarily
through the sending school but in the
receiving center
so they don't have to avoid going to a
program because they have to remain home
at that sending school to receive that
one algebra course or that chemistry
course now it's embedded into the
courses and the programs the studies of
the cte
that program is is is critical
and
coupled with the emergency situation not
i wouldn't call it emergency but it
makes our garage much safer we all know
the condition that is in
and
that is going to be a problem within the
next what is a problem right now so that
that is key
to
i think all of our positions right here
and we got to try to work together here
on this other stuff that's been added to
it
uh likened to that christmas tree
with too many bulbs on it i think has
represented our senator guy to mention
on the senate floor
so
i would encourage us all to try to work
together to try to get to that in the
net that is resolved
um
thank you
so is there any further discussion on
this right now we will be resourcing for
our next one which is we're going to
have to come to the table with some
answers
so i suggest that we work carefully
together on that
as we have been doing senator bradley um
what time would you like to come back
tomorrow
what is what time do these reports have
to be end to
three o'clock two is it just nine a.m i
would suggest nine o'clock too
and i would think we'd bring our lunch
too
okay
so we will recess this meeting till
three a nine o'clock tomorrow morning
thursday
and um we'll conclude things then thank
you very much
we're done
with my job
i felt like bringing both mine down
you